auf dauer müssen wir in deutschland viel
weniger auto fahren das ist tatsache
den massenhaften individualverkehr
können wir uns so nicht mehr leisten
deswegen hat unser verkehrsministerium
jetzt ein spannendes pilotprojekt
gestartet unter der leitung von albrecht
humboldt albrecht was genau machen sie
da etwas unglaubliches oliver absolutes
neuland wir wollen und kein mensch weiß
ob das überhaupt geht einen deutschen
von seinem auto trennen ihn ein ja doch
denn wenn wir das schaffen dann ist
alles möglich
leider ist unsere versuchspersonen der
verklemmten im moment ein wenig
aufgewühlt wegen der drohenden
fahrverbote er hat sich vor 36 stunden
hier eingeschlossen
[Gelächter]
ich glaube ich habe hunger
das hat doch keinen sinn fast wobei ein
auto hat fast kleinlaut ich fast mit
euch machen
so jetzt haben wir uns alle wieder
beruhigt was genau müsste der staat in
den herrn klempnow anbieten damit er auf
sein auto verzichtet neues auto nein
eben nicht mein gott unser angebot
kostenlose öffentliche verkehrsmittel
und das tollste ist die bushaltestelle
ist gleicher form
das sind keine zehn metern cool taxi
in umfragen hat man herausgefunden was
begeisterte autofahrer an bus und bahn
wirklich stört der kontakt zu anderen
menschen werden könnten männer das sind
die anderen fahrgäste in meinem bus ja
die fahren hier auch mit warum es stinke
der umstieg vom auto auf öffis geht eben
nur in ganz ganz kleinen schritten aber
es gibt tricks man kann zb das erlebnis
auto fahren im bus nach stellen so der
herr klempnow hat jetzt leider
lebenslanges hausverbot in allen bussen
von nordrhein-westfalen andere idee wir
zahlen ihnen eine prämie wenn sie dieses
elektroauto kaufen
[Gelächter]
ok dann ein nagelneues fahrrad muss ich
machen der anders machen
sie wollen nicht zug fahren nicht bus
fahren nicht fahrrad fahren sie wollen
keinen carsharing was zum teufel können
wir als staat beim machen damit sie
ihren prinz louis diesen lügen neuen
tollen also meinen dank stehen lassen
nachbau der partei stehen jedoch
schuldig
noch nicht
oh mann
[Applaus]